[Music]
thank you
welcome to another episode of what's up
rough
hello Martin hello Walter
I'm okay and you
I'm getting there slowly yeah it takes a
little bit longer than when we were 20
years old
correct
but we know where we can draw our
strings are you talking about increments
of 20 years
I'm at the second increment already
well been through a little bit of a job
experience but getting there crawling
out of the hole well the end of job is
what it was all about let's hope so so
let's open with the word of pray
our heavenly father thank you for giving
us the opportunity to do these
discussions again
we ask that you Enlighten our minds with
the Holy Spirit and Lord give us the
strength to do this in Jesus name amen
amen
Martin
somehow
we were impressed to talk about
worship and song
and what does one do in the light of the
overwhelming input
from the world
in terms of Music Styles and worship
styles
what is appropriate what is not
appropriate
these are difficult questions and they
create great controversy that's for sure
there's many people that are a bit
perturbed when it comes to the music
Styles so you were in the Rave culture
would you bring the rave music into the
church
yeah well we tried it when in the
beginning not when I became an Adventist
but when my Christian walk started to
catch up again
we try to do Christian rave music
and do you think it's appropriate no
today by the way
when you face that DJ
isn't that a form of worship well
actually they there's a lot of that that
says that music is a religion yes it is
a religion it's a religion and uh
I mean if you just look at the the like
you said the DJ in the front or even for
that matter doesn't matter even if it's
an artist he's in the front they've got
all the attention attention everybody's
hands are in the air and they're
swinging or crying or jumping up and
down and everybody is focused towards
and then you bring that into the church
until then worshiping the same deity
that you worshiped in the rife culture
and that's unfortunately how it is all
right so this is a tricky question and
people have
favorite music Styles and they
well they they think that they can just
transform them and bring them into the
church you see that's where the problem
is and sometimes I say okay but you can
use that music to reach people there
so
if I decide now I'm going back to the
Rave scene
to go and Reach people there will that
work
I doubt it Martin I doubt it you have to
come out of that system you have to
leave it behind
and you have to re-learn what it is all
about we serve a high and holy God
and music should approach as near as
possible to the music in heaven
and the Heavenly choirs
and the question of course is what do
the Heavenly Choirs do can you in your
mind's eye see them
doing Christian rock
no not after the studies that I've done
and now I start to realize
how God what God is all about so
irrespective of the genre that you are
accustomed to or that you enjoy
there are certain changes that have to
take place so there must be a
reprogramming
now
the trouble is that when they try to
retain people in the churches
and there have been a number of
experiments like that by changing our
churches into that kind of cultural
setting yes
and if you look at the history and you
look at the fruits thereof
most of them have left yes they've
become Sunday churches that's it I think
while you're talking about it there was
this one project
I think it's still going yes but that's
one of the and many churches have lived
they've lived because the the style
draws you back into your original
culture which they claim is not so
restrictive and more loose and all of
these things
so what do we do and how do you change
now I'm a much older generation than
than you are
I grew up in the age of The Beatles And
The Rolling Stones by the way
some of these old codgers are still
going that's it and they haven't changed
their tune but now it's interesting that
you mentioned those two because actually
according to the image out there they
are opposed to each other yes the
Beatles are the more conservative nice
and the
Rolling Stones are these real rockers
and they are blatantly satanistic
sympathy with the devil all of these
things but let's not but what I wanted
to say just is actually
The Beatles are not any better no they
said they were more popular than Jesus
and all the things that they implemented
the Eastern mysticism everything that
they brought in correct now I was never
really into any of those in a big way
when I was a buffer
I was more into almost psychedelic type
music like
like The Moody Blues
these were educated people but they
there was a Nuance in the music and a
vibration and the music that was
differently below the belt you see it
what's interesting is every genre of
music has got also its drug that
accompanies it yes
and then I you know later changed to
more
uh country and western type music and
some of some of the music was very
melodious like Roger Whittaker and all
of those singers
and the question is because you like it
in the world is it appropriate in the
church difficult question difficult so
what are the Heavenly choirs all about
well you can gain a glimpse
if you go to your Bible and you see what
kinds of instruments
were created for the worship of God what
instruments were acceptable which were
not
David in his first attempt to bring the
ark back
made a few mistakes
and it cost him dearly
and then there are a few Corrections
and there were trained singers
and they were they were not a small
crowd no and they were male and female
voices that had to sing and they had to
harmonize Harmony is one of the the
higher levels of music it's the
intellectual level
so you have Melody you have rhythm you
have Harmony
and there must be a certain
blend which is appropriate for a high
and holy God I am Holy so be ye holy
so let's have a look at this subject
we've called it it Is Well with My Soul
that is of course also the title of him
right yeah
let's look at some of these things
is a letter from 18
50. in the spirit of Prophecy and it
says I saw we must be constantly Rising
and keep the ascendancy above the powers
of Darkness
I saw singing to the glory of God often
drove the enemy and shouting would beat
him back and give us the victory now
this issue of shouting
what is this is this a Bedlam of noise
or is it a holy shout a music with a
crescendo now I'm sure it's that and
it's not the Rock voice that screeches
at a high shout correct so the Bible
often talks about
the shouting in other words singing with
your full capacity yes that's what it
means
all right when you shout don't you raise
your voice yes
so when you sing and you call it a shout
don't you raise your voice Raise Your
Voice okay into a guttural sound or must
it still be harmonious and melodious and
all of these things yes
right so singing can beat back the enemy
and the more in trouble you are the more
you can sing with gusto
that's basically what it means right not
sing with a whimper yeah
I saw there was too little glorifying
God in Israel and two little childlike
simplicity
those are two very important points yeah
we did the
childlike Simplicity you have to glorify
God
so it mustn't be self-centered it
mustn't be World centered it must be
god-centered
and you have to have chart like
simplicity
in other words you have to have the
basic tenants
that make it pleasing to there
I asked the angel why there was not more
power in Israel said he
he let go of the promises of God too
quickly press your petition to the
throne and Hold On by faith
if singing is a form of Prayer
if singing is a form of worship then
does it contain petitions yes
all right so is it a repetitive Mantra
or is it a petition
petition so as soon as it becomes a
repetitive Mantra it loses all the
influence of it and the Bible clearly
says then you are like the pagans
believe you receive the things you ask
for and you shall have them
so if a song is a prayer
then it's also a request it can be a
glorification it can be Thanksgiving it
can be all of those
but it can also be a request yes
a Bedlam of noise shocks the senses and
perverts that which if conducted or
right might be a blessing
so The Godly shouting or The Godly
singing with Gus though can that be in
any way in harmony with the Bedlam of
noise no
no huh
no no noise no
so shouting and screaming and using a
voice where you almost become hoarse
because of your utterances
that doesn't seem appropriate right
the powers of satanic agencies blend
with the DIN and noise to have a
carnival and this is termed the holy
spirit's working
don't we see that on a large scale
in Rave cultures at rock concerts yeah
now you've got that problem and in
churches that's the thing because the
problem is because you are used to it in
the secular
Melia once you go to the church it's
easier to bring that over into there as
well
and then it doesn't shock you actually
anymore no because you're used to it so
that's a difficult thing because once
you get used to this
to get rid of it
you have to come in harmony with what
God wants
so what the world does isn't that to
desensitize you 100 to the finer
principles of a prayer when when you
have this kind of culture and you are
all in this
this mood
are you then really praying to an
outside Source or are you satisfying a a
craving a feeling a feeling yeah
okay those things which have been in the
past will be in the future
Satan will make music a snare by the way
in which it is conducted
let us give no place to strange
exercisings which will really take the
Mind away from the deep movings of the
Holy Spirit
God's work is ever characterized by
calmness
and dignity
jumping around screaming
gesticulating is that calmness and
dignity no
no but of course you've got a problem
because then there's what about the
dancing that was done towards the Lord
but there was always an a war setting
when the people went out to meet the
army
has to come to the context again correct
when they came back to the temple it was
an act of worship and then that was not
included yeah
is another statement from Martin Luther
and Martin Luther had some very
interesting things to say you know he
was very involved in music
and he wrote some wonderful hymns I have
no use for cranks who despise music
because it is a gift of God music drives
away the devil and makes people joyful
they forget thereby all wrath unchastity
arrogance and the like
next after theology I give to music the
highest place and the greatest honor
so again does it drive away demons yes
all right now if the music is exactly
the same as in a rave culture or in a
rock concert
are the demons quite comfortable in that
setting yes unfortunately that's how it
is okay
is another quote by him we cannot Vex
the devil more
than by teaching
preaching
singing
and talking of Jesus
is that in harmony with what we read in
the spirit of Prophecy indifferently
therefore I like it well when with
sounding voice
is that a loud voice that's a loud voice
but it's not shocking the senses okay
so when with sounding voice we sing in
the church is
the devil cannot endure these words and
flies away for he well feels what is
contained therein oh how happy a thing
worried did we find as much joy in these
words as the devil is a frightened of
them I'm going to say Martin what the
frights him those words
so what does it
means
it means and he became a man and the
word became flesh so again
it's christ-centered exactly and as soon
as something is christ-centered and not
self-centered the devil cannot stand it
yeah because Christ and the devil are at
enmity with each other
where Christ is worshiped
and Satan cannot
cannot participate no he has to flee he
has to go
so it's very important that we realize
when we have an act of worship
that it's not generic
true it has to be very specific yeah
okay
but the world condemns God's words and
works because they are delivered to them
in a plain and simple manner
well the good and godly are not offended
thereof for they have regard to the
Everlasting Celestial treasure and
wealth which therein lies hit
and which is so precious and glorious
that the Angels Delight in beholding it
all right so are angels involved when we
sing definitely when we sing about Jesus
yes
when we sing about salvation yeah when
we honor him as Creator when we honor
him as Lord giver when we obey him are
they delighted definitely do they obey
him yes well it makes me think of when
Jesus was born the Angels were singing
to the Shepherds yes and what were they
singing they were singing Glory to God
in the highest right because
there was
exactly what it says there exactly God
became flesh the word became flesh even
when you go to job that you mentioned
this sons of God were singing they were
singing
and even the Bible mentions that God
sings yes and that Jesus will be singing
he will Joy over them with singing now
so this will be very fascinating uh that
must be the ultimate singing When God
himself sings right I must yeah I can't
wait I can't wait either
someone let's look at a simple hymn
such as it Is Well with My Soul
and look at the history behind the hymn
what moved the people to write these
hymns you see was it just some Airy
fairy experience or was it some deep
significant time in a person's life they
see the thing is
especially the younger generation and
I'll take myself in with that as well
when first you if you're not used to
hymns because you're used to all these
other types of music and then at first
you say look we'll have to do something
funny daddies we will have to do
something you'll never do something
about it you see what was mentioned in
the spirit of Prophecy earlier
it's not only
you have to look at the whole conduction
of the song then you're going to start
understanding what it means so if you do
when conducted or right that's the word
so it's not just the lyrics
but the whole
structure of the song is you can't just
take lyrics and put it into a worldly
setting no
there's always this um the argument yes
that people use they always tell you
yeah but I'm not actually listening to
this song but the the lyrics are
beautiful yes well then you can ask the
question
if you've got a quite
ugly photo
of something perverse and you put a nice
caption on it yeah a Biblical caption
it's not going to make the the picture
better no and that's why once you've got
the structure right and you then got
this beautiful lyrics it just opens up a
whole new meaning to it
so the words of this song are when peace
like a river
attendeth my way when Sorrows like sea
below's role
whatever my Lata has taught me to say it
is well it Is Well with My Soul
so this person is obviously in deep
sorrow
but he has peace like a river
and then it says then the refrain It Is
Well with My Soul It is Well it Is Well
with My Soul
my sin of the joy of this glorious
thought my sin not in part but the whole
is nailed to the cross and I bear it no
more praise the Lord praise the Lord O
my soul
is there Doctrine in that verse yeah
lots of Doctrine all right so the
circumstances surrounding him are
definitely not Rosy
and there is sorrow in his soul
and is looking at the sea
and the rolling waves
and they remind him of something that he
sorrowful
but then the peace comes from a Doctrine
that he sinned not the in part but the
whole is nailed to the cross and I bear
it no more praise the Lord praise the
Lord O my soul
is there a message yes
salvation
and Lord has the day when my faith shall
be sight
in other words I now live by faith and
I'm waiting for for that day when I will
actually see it yes like is mentioned in
a previous one we talked about
there will be no faith when we get to
heaven no you don't need Faith because
reality has taken its place
the clouds be rolled back as a scroll
the Trump shall ReSound then the Lord
shall descend even so it Is Well with My
Soul Is there comfort in them yes so
even though it can be sorrowful or
you're looking at this wonderful day
it's still a well with yourself so does
it tell you that you can be in deep
sorrow
and yet if you keep your eyes fixed on
the promise
then you can have peace yeah like a
river
okay
so if we look at the story of this song
Horatio spafford 1828 to 1888 was a
successful lawyer
real estate investor in Chicago he and
his wife Anna had one son and four
daughters
and lived a life of philanthropy and
service in their Church they were good
Christians
well to do well off
recognized in society
philanthropy that helped the poor they
did everything a good Christian should
do
until 1871 that is in that year they
lost their four-year-old son to scarlet
fever
and a few months later the Great Chicago
Fire wiped out the majority of their
Property Holdings
sounds like job story
they made it through the next two years
until 1873 tragedy struck again the
spaffords had planned to visit Europe as
a family
but business kept the ratio behind and
on the voyage the ship Anna and their
four daughters were traveling on struck
another vessel and sank rapidly
only Anna survived she sent a hauntingly
brief telegram to Horatio bearing the
words
saved alone
one can only imagine spafford's grief
upon receiving the news it must have
been paralyzing
but on his own Voyage to meet Anna as
his ship neared the place where his
daughters had drowned
he was inspired to write the lyrics for
the hymn it was Well with My Soul
unlike many heartbreak songs it focuses
Less on what was lost
and more on where hope can be found no
doubt spafford was shattered by the loss
of his daughters
but his heart turned to the faithfulness
of God in the midst of loss and the work
of Jesus to rescue sinners
the hymn does not diminish or gloss over
pain and tragedy
but rather proclaims that God is present
in them and greater than them
would you say that is Meaningful oh
that's what this Plan of Salvation and
the Bible is all about so if you're
going through a hard time
isn't this the kind of him you would
want to sing absolutely
you know what even if you go through a
good time
this is the image you want to want to
sing okay
Jesus calms the storm and when he had
entered into a ship Matthew chapter 8
from verse 23.
his disciples followed them and behold
there arose a great Tempest in the sea
in so much as the ship was covered with
waves but he was asleep
was he an absentee landlord
oh man yeah that's how they fought and
his disciples came to him and walked him
and saying Lord save us we perish
in another gospel that says don't you
care yeah
right
and he says unto them why are you
fearful oh ye little of little faith
then he arose and rebuked the winds and
the Sea and there was a great calm peace
like a river that's it that storm that
rages but first the storm then the
reaction what was the reaction
to seek Jesus
so Martin when we worship
And We Worship in the midst of the
storms of life
what is the solution
Jesus seek Jesus rise it
okay but the men marveled saying what
manner of man is this that even the
winds and the Sea obey him
so they're looking at the physical again
and they miss the spiritual message
so how do you gain spiritual experience
by Calamity it seems
that's unfortunately the Bible is full
of it
full of it and you have to learn lessons
even the spirit of Prophecy is full of
it read testimonies volume one just
diminish to the church it's absolutely
amazing and you either get to
where job's wife was Coast Guard and die
or you say even if you slay me yet will
I serve him
one of the two and then you sing it Is
Well with My Soul correct
all right so in verse 1 there was this
issue of the storm so we saw the story
in the Bible the storm is to connect you
with Christ yeah or else the storm will
take your piece away
and you will disintegrate
so the storm is there to connect you to
Christ now in verse 2
it talks about the Plan of Salvation my
sins not in part but the whole
the condition of pardon the steps to
Salvation is acknowledged
repent
believe
transform
would you agree with that you have to
and if you skip some of these it's it
it's not full repentance all right so
any any uh worship of God
must come from a heart of gratitude
because how can you worship God if
you're not grateful that's it or you
worship him out of fear
cannot work
like my atheistic mother-in-law is to
say why do I need to pray I worked for
this food
and I asked her but you you created so
that you could eat it
so you have to acknowledge
you have to repent you have to believe
you have to transform so without
transformation the foregoing
are meaningless
so there must be a result
it can't just be a daily routine like
reading the newspaper no
those who were waiting to make
themselves more worthy as another quote
of divine favor before they venture to
claim the promises of God we're making a
fatal mistake
Jesus alone cleanses from sin he only
can forgive our transgression he has
pledged himself to listen to the
petition and Grant the prayer of those
who come to him in faith
many have a vague idea that they must
make some wonderful effort
in order to gain the favor of God I'm
not ready to go to God yet
because I haven't fixed this thing yet
that's what they say isn't it that's it
but all self-dependence is vain it is
only by connecting with Jesus through
faith
that the sinner becomes a hopeful
believing child of God
button if we do not
have these elements
in our worship which includes Our Song
then we are actually vain
that's God doesn't like vain no because
it's a religious experience and a
religious experience is christ-centered
now we also had justification in that
right
my sin not in part but the whole has
been nailed to the crust and I bear it
no more yeah
so justification we teach that men
cannot be justified before God by their
own strength merits or works
but are freely Justified for Christ's
sake through faith
when they believe that they are received
into favor and that their sins are
forgiven for Christ's sake who by his
death has made satisfaction for our sins
this faith God accounts as righteousness
in his sight
quoting Romans 3 and 4.
would you agree with that statement I
agree with that statement okay now
Martin where does that come from this
comes from the Augsburg confession all
right now who wrote the Oxbow confession
it was melanthon
when Longton wrote it and they had a
very deep
understanding of justification
and the spirit of Prophecy clearly says
that they had a right understanding
of justification so it is it is good to
read it
so let's read it again we teach that men
cannot be justified before God by their
own strength merits or works but of
really Justified for Christ's sake
through faith
when they believe that they are received
into favor and that their sins are
forgiven for Christ's sake who by his
death has made satisfaction for our sins
this faith God accounts as righteousness
in his sight quoting Romans 3 and 4.
does the Roman Catholic Church deny that
yes yes they call it anathema
so by the article of justification your
faith stands or Falls
and anybody who doesn't receive the
article of justification
cannot be worshiping the same God
you cannot
because the one says by faith the other
one says by works correct
article 12 is about repentance now
repentance consists properly of two
parts one is contrition that is
terrorists might think the conscience
through the knowledge of sin
the other is faith which born of the
Gospel or of absolution believes for
Christ's sake that sins are forgiven
Comforts the conscience and delivers it
from Terrors then good works are bound
to follow being the fruits of repentance
would you agree with that statement 100
percent
works is an outflow of repentance so
first the one then the other and the
other you can't reverse them if you put
that you have negated Christ totally you
have negated the cross you have negated
the blood
no wonder the Jesuits annoy me to the
extent to which they annoy me because
they ignore the very basics in the Bible
true
well I just want to bring something in
with justification and that
sanctification
now while I understand sanctification is
that as justification if we take for
instance the thief on the cross Jesus
Justified him and actually Sanctified
him
yes but then he was if he would have
come down from the cross he would have
done the same as all of us he would have
had to go and stay Sanctified in other
words allow Christ to work in him yes
and keep on right so justification is a
Judicial decree
it is a legal concept
sanctification
imparted righteousness is just as much
much a gift as justification it is not
something that you are pulling up your
socks by yourself you are allowing
Christ to change you actually and yes
and stay there not to work against from
the bottom to the top yes and seeing
that you have a human nature
you will stumble and fall but you have
to keep your eyes fixed on the cross and
you have to constantly ask Christ to
work within you the altar that's how it
works
now verse 3 in that song is about the
Advent hope can you see a progression oh
for sure well it started off like we
said actually in the first one is Jesus
the second verse first one is sorrow
sorrow then the sanctification and then
the hope but it's constantly the
dependence on Jesus right so we move to
the Advent hub
so
there is a message there is a Theology
and it is in harmony with the Bible
those are the elements we're not talking
about a specific aim and saying Allah
people please sing that hymn every
single day because then it becomes a
mantra too we're talking about the
principles of what constitutes a song of
worship
now here's another hymn hymn number 154
When I Survey the Wondrous Cross
just go through that one
When I Survey the Wondrous Cross on
which the prince of Glory died
my richest gain I count but loss and
poor contempt on All My Pride
what about the Theology of that verse
Martin
is a deep oh yeah
what does it do to man's Glory
it lays it in the dust right
the spirit of Prophecy says
justification is laying man's glory in
the dust
and here we have our Glory laid in the
dust that pour contempt on All My Pride
forbid it Lord that I should boast safe
in the death of Christ my God
all the vain things that charm me most I
sacrifice them to his blood
is that a willingness to give up the
things of the world everything
all not cling unto one little bit
all right now but if you if you just
sing this like
or if you sing this
participating in the message
well can I change something it has to
well that's maybe one thing that we can
implore people to
that's happened to to me and my wife
once we started singing this and really
listen and get into the doctrine that
you're singing correct now Paul says
when I do these things I I do them
I do them by the spirit I do it with a
heart but I do it with my mind also the
two must be constantly connected you
cannot disconnect them because then your
feelings can go on a rampage
that's true but here you are kept within
the structure
see from his head his hands his feet
sorrow and love flow mingled down that's
very poetic
did air such love and sorrow meet or
Thorns compose so rich a crown
that's pretty deep eh
but have we lost our depth
and have moved towards
simple refrains that roll easily of the
tongue but don't necessarily require
much thought that's true
well that's a problem
because I think we want to just sit
there and enjoy and not think about
anything then you don't think then you
are having a relaxing session
and you run a campfire and you're
singing now I'm not saying we shouldn't
do that
but when it comes to real worship when
it comes to true worship
don't you want to have deep things to
talk and sing about yes I think so
where the whole realm of nature mine
that were an offering far too small love
so amazing So Divine divine's my soul my
life my all
Martin are you willing to sing that yes
I want to
it's a tremendous decision it is because
once you've done that there's no turning
back
okay
all right this hymn is based on
Galatians 6 14.
but God forbid that I should boast save
in the cross of our Lord Jesus Christ
the prolific Charles Wesley who wrote
more than six thousand hymns reportedly
said he would give up all his hymns to
have written this one
and pour contempt on All My Pride
interesting right and that's how I we
should feel okay so what was the hymn
based on
doctor that's it and getting rid of your
pride
okay so let's look at the history of him
so when I surveyed the Wondrous Cross
by Isaac Watts
When I Survey the Wondrous Cross on
which the prince of Glory died my
richest gain I count but lost and poor
contempt on All My Pride one of the
greatest hymn writers of all time
composed the beautiful hymn When I
Survey the Wondrous Cross
Isaac Watts was born in England the
first son of a family of the dissenting
tradition
though his training in Greek Latin and
Hebrew would have allowed him the
opportunity to become an Anglican priest
he chose to pass the a dissenting
congregation
another one of those Rebels right
now it's interesting that uh Wesley said
it would give up everything to have
written that him that Isaac Watts wrote
right
at the time of what's birth churches in
England sang Only metrical Psalms
but by the time of his death he had
planted the seed of a much more complex
hymnnadi
his 600 hymns found in seven collections
made the transition from a rigid
metrical psalmadi
to a Freer theologically based hymnity
now remember where they came from they
came out of the Middle Ages
where music was often a mood inducer and
was often chaunted
especially when you got to the Catholic
church it was the whole time
a very specific way correct and now God
is raising up the Reformation
and he's teaching them something
it went something different in the music
now if God taught them this Martin
something we should hold on to
true
but
don't people have the same argument
today that they might have to change it
a little bit to get to the times all
right but let's look at the principles
we're looking at the principles so
what's hymns include a complex Theology
and a format that is ideal for
congregational singing
hymns should Echo the theme of the
sermon
he insisted that songs in the church
should be fully Evangelical and not just
supplements to the Psalms that hymns
should be freely composed and not just
hold the letter of scripture
and that him should give straightforward
Expressions so that thoughts and
feelings of the singers not merely
recall events of the distant past in
other words you must participate in it
it must be a lively interaction you can
quote scripture but you can use the
scripture homiletically you can say what
you feel and what you gained out of what
you read
he also wrote texts to fit the most
common Psalm meters allowing them to be
sung by any congregation
to a variety of Tunes in such a way that
each line contained a complete thought
this was important since the hymns like
the metrical Psalms before them were
lined out by presenter or song leader
the leader would sing a phrase and then
the congregation would Echo back what
had been sung
if a thought were spread out over two
phrases it would be broken up by this
teaching technique what smoothed out the
process
by including a complete thought in a
single phrase as much as possible
all right now if you if you look at that
method
a complete thought in a single phrase
that's easy to internalize that's also
actually making it easy to remember yes
and if you add rhyme
then it's easier to remember
that's why you can you can use the
scripture
and introduce rhyme in order so that it
is easier to memorize
another example of the impact of his
theology upon his hymns
is that he edited text based on the Old
Testament to reflect the presence of
Christ
causing his enmity to view God the
father from the perspective of God the
son
that's amazing in other words he was
interpreting
the Old Testament
and using it as a Expositor of the new
right and that's exactly what it's
supposed to do even in preaching
correct so the original fourth stanza of
the Sim is actually omitted though it
inspires quite a powerful image
his dying Crimson like a robe spreads or
his body on the tree
then I am dead to all the globe and all
the globe is dead to me
it's interesting that they leave that
one out yeah I quite like it
it's very theological
it is very deep and it also has this
idea
that you separate yourself from the
world yeah
the world has no place in the church no
nothing
God said we are in this world but not of
this world correct does this take away
the joy and the experience no not at all
now if it's scriptural then it should
actually increase it
well this totally makes you think then
about that guy remember a while back we
had that guy that was running up and
down screaming
nonsense of only the Saturday or God is
the god of the Monday the Tuesday and
the Sunday the Wednesday the whatever so
how do you
bring that with these type of music it's
as far removed as the East is from the
west and if you raise your hands and and
give accolades to something like that
then it is best to walk right out of
that church and say this has become the
house of demons it's a Bedlam of noise
yes now you see the thing is people say
that you can okay use that music to go
and get people and reach them where they
are and bring them here but then if you
bring them here and all of a sudden they
listen to this they're going to say to
you what what's going on here exactly
so the last two lines of the stanza form
a chiasmus
as him knowledges J Richard Watson note
a crossing over on the manner of the
Greek letter G it is found in the great
fourth verse which takes the idea from
Galatians 6 40. not the cross that is
formed between the words dead and globe
in those two lines
When I Survey the Wondrous crisp is one
of what's finest poems and an excellent
example of why is considered a fulcrum
in the transition to himnadi
the Reverend Carlton young editor of the
um Hymnal notes that this hymn is
clearly something different
than what's earlier poems that might be
characterized as devotional poetry or as
Psalm paraphrases several hymnologists
have noted that this hymn first
published in the hymns and spiritual
songs 1707 is an excellent example
of many of his best techniques such as
his ability to write beginning lines
which capture one's attention maintain a
theme and build to a climax
writing a hymn
is a complex process yes
because it has got a whole construction
that like we mentioned before it's not
just about we're writing lyrics okay
does it have emotion yes
does that feeling
does it have Doctrine Doctrine
definitely is it christ-centered yes
does it have salvation yes and the
issues of Salvation yes
yeah and then the structure of it it's
got rhythm it's got structure it's got
Melody it's got Harmony
all of it in there
so in the um him know the text is set in
two different Tunes the first Hamburg by
American Lao Mason was written in 1824
this tune originated from Gregorian
chant
presumably the benedictos
so that's what happened in the Middle
Ages in the medieval church right
and was first published in the Third
Edition of the Boston Handel and Haydn
Society collection of church music the
second tune Rockingham composed by
Englishman Edward Miller in 1790 was
first matched with the text in hymns
ancient and modern
the hymn is particularly powerful
because it includes many poetic devices
for example
oxymoron is found twice in the first
stanza my richest gain I count but lost
that's an oxymoronia
because how can your loss be again right
and poor contempt on All My Pride
that again is an oxymoron so there's a
technique here the third standard
contains a paradox
in a crown of thorns and there are two
rhetorical questions in the second half
of the stanza did air such love and
sorrow meat or Thorns compose so rich a
crown
and the piece ends with the climax
demands my soul my life my all so
there's a deep theology
there is this oxymoron that
two opposites become a reality faith is
the substance of things hope for the
evidence of Things Not Seen that's an
oxymoron that's oxymoron it's very
biblical it's a very biblical oxymoron
even the spirit of process prophecy uses
this type of language correct and if you
don't have it then you cannot please God
so you have to accept the oxymoron
that's it and that means you must accept
justification yeah
so when I survey as a hymn which is
saturated with Theology and a call for
an emotional response from the singer
so emotion is involved emotion is
involved the hymn was transformed into a
statement of faith
that crosses denominational lines and
generations according to him scholar
Lionel ADI the lines all the vain things
that charm me most I sacrifice them have
a meaning personal to each singer
so you can actually sing that song and
relate it to yourself yes it can be for
the whole congregation singing together
but it's also very individualistic right
so you're not just singing someone
else's Mantra yeah and the same with
this um emotion like we mentioned
earlier there is emotion involved but it
must be in the right order you cannot
let that be the main driving force yes
so one that might require either action
or renunciation the three pledges at the
climax of the hymn my soul my life my
all are a sacrifice that had once been
required only of those taking monastic
vows
now it's required of you but these
monastic vows were of course
totally in a wrong Channel yeah
because they were associated with
self-mutilation yeah it once again
selfishness actually now self-mutilation
doesn't that negate the cross yeah
absolutely
so the Theology of the same functions
powerfully in the context of a worship
service
Eddie continues about to receive the
sacrament the poet meditates upon the
love that turned that instrument of
judicial torture and death
into the channel of divine compassion
the same as a masterpiece that marks the
genius of one man and his influence on
millions of singers throughout the ages
as Dr Young says to him successfully
built a bridge from samadhi to himnidi
and set the church free to create a
living body of Christian praise in songs
that was what God intended it must
become personalized but it must be
rooted in scripture that's it
now let's look at another him Martin
we're using these hymns as examples
to look at structure to look at
methodologies to look at what it should
really entail
and we're not saying to focus only on
this but to take the general message out
of it
so that you can mull it over what does
it mean to worship God especially when
you're using song yes
now this one is a little bit Freer my
Jesus I love thee I know Thou Art mine
for thee all the Follies of sin I resign
my gracious Redeemer My Savior ought
thou If Ever I love thee my Jesus tis
now this is a joyful song right
and there's gratefulness in it
right there is a response to the cross
in it yeah
should we have that in our hymns yes
there must be a
it must be an outflow of gratefulness
correct
I love thee because thou Hast first
loved me and purchased my pardon on
calvary's tree I love thee for wearing
the thorns on thy brow If Ever I love
thee my Jesus it is now is their
theology in that beautiful
hmm
I love thee in life I will love thee
till death and praise thee as long as
thou lendeth me breath and say when the
death you lies cold on my brow If Ever I
love thee my Jesus tis now
so how long is this process of love
going to continue
until the end until then throughout your
entire life
and if you lose this gratefulness
if you lose sight of this cross then
you've lost
and you've lost your Christian
experience right
and that's what so is him there to
remind you of your Christian experience
yes and to pick you up when you're down
and to help you out of the gutter when
you really just can't
keep with it and then also once you get
out of there
to joyfully say thank you all right so
what is this final outcome
in mentions of glory and endless Delight
I'll ever adore thee in heaven so bright
I'll sing with a glittering crown on my
brow If Ever I love thee my Jesus does
now so you know whatever happens to you
in this life this is the promise
people want to hear and now experience
that's it remember that prostitute that
we discussed in the absentee landlord
she said he's taken his reward with him
he's taken the money back
what what's the good of that come come
come I will I will supply your needs now
now
so what's the history of the same and
why did this person write it
it was written by William R Featherstone
my Jesus I love thee I know Thou Art
mine for thee all the Follies of Sinner
resigned my gracious Redeemer My Savior
Art Thou If Ever I love thee my Jesus is
now the text of this favorite to him
especially of Northern evangelicals was
likely written at the conversion
of author William Ralph Featherstone
when he was a teenager
there's a reason why we chose this one
because he was a teenager and
is there a lot of teenagers these days
busy with music especially in the church
and which don't feel like hymns are a
little bit boring boring all right but
it was converted
[Music]
did he understand the conversion that he
went through yes he did
so I must have mulled it over he must
have studied the scripture it's based on
scripture
it's an outflow of the complete
understanding that he had yes it's not a
complex hymn
the Simplicity and sincerity of the text
has resonated with Christians for well
over 150 years particularly as a Hymn of
invitation or prayer hymn
so featherston
sometimes called Featherstone
was born in Montreal Quebec Canada
where his parents were members of the
Wesleyan Methodist Church
the Reverend Carlton young editor of the
um Hymnal suggests that the hymn was
composed sometime between the author's
conversion 1858 and when he was included
in the London hymn book little else is
known of featherston
the stanza emitted in the urine himmo
appears as the third standard in many
hymnals I will love thee in life I will
love thee in death and praise thee as
long as thou lendeth me breath
and say when the death you lies called
on my brow If Ever I love thee my Jesus
tis now
a young man in his teenage years
thinking of the death due on his brow
so this stanza has the earmarks of 19th
century romantic hymnadi
with its focus on death the final
standard of losing to Mansions of Glory
in heaven serves the same purpose in a
more positive way
it actually shows you
yes it is a sad day but there's hope as
well in that
stanzas 2 and 3 and 4 of the original
hymn each include a reference to brow
as a unifying theme wearing thorns on
thy brow death you lies called on my
brow glittering crown on my brow
so there's something to put it into your
mind it's actually nice he's repeating
it but it's not repetitive
that's a very good point Martin
the other unifying theme is the final
line of each stanza If Ever I love thee
my Jesus tis now
this focus on the singer's Love Of
Christ permeates the hymn from the first
line
if all four of the original stanzas are
included the words love or love appear
ten times
interesting yeah
other expressions of affection include
gracious Redeemer ever adore thee like
many hymns of this era this one
expresses total Devotion to Christ in
the language of intimacy
is that a theme that we can introduce
into our music we have to
but it mustn't be superficial it must be
because this comes from the heart it
comes in it's an outflow from what it
feels yes
all right so there was a more
simplistic
but it it still had all the criteria
of what it means to serve Christ isn't
it interesting
little child we as children and then
you've got a teenager writing this
beautiful hymn correct so it shows that
Simplicity is not nearly as complicated
as the previous previous one but the end
result is the same the end result is the
same and it depends on the stage that
you are in in your Christian experience
obviously he hasn't got deep theology
like Martin Luther would put into his
songs
but it is christ-centered I sent it the
meaning is wonderful
now one of my favorite hymns
Martin
one of my favorite hymns
is and can it be
and I love singing this song because
it is so rich in theology
IT addresses the entire essence of the
scriptures the deity of Christ
not as a generated being
as taught in Catholicism
but as one with the father from the
beginning not the created being either
correct
and it was written by Wesley
as we will see
and if we look at the words of this song
and if you look at the melody it's good
it's got a catchy theme
and you can sing it in a stereotype way
or you could sing it with gusto
and I I'm often reminded of uh James
White who would take his Bible you know
must I take my Bible no you don't
actually I'm not going to open it I'm
just going to keep it close that's what
we're going to do and when when the
congregation sang as though they were
singing funeral songs
I've been in many churches where you
want to die because it sounds like a
funeral every time
then he would say come on
I need to tell them to get with it and
sing with gusto
so you can sing this was Gus though too
and you can take it to a crescendo yeah
yes
that's the thing you know every hymn
that you sing yes if you sing it even if
it's a prayer for you sing it with
compassion then it changes the whole the
words in there
why don't you read the same okay why
should it be me sure because this is
your favorite hymn but I've sang it many
times with you okay
and can it be
that I should gain an interest in the
savior's blood
daddy for me who caused his pain for me
who him to death pursued
amazing love how can it be that thou my
God should die for me well that's an
amazing theology in that yeah right you
have to save his blood in there
he died for you
all things that Catholicism denies
and we are the ones who cause this pain
and what he died for me
who pursued him to death I'm just as
responsible for the death of Christ as
were the Pharisees of old yeah
amazing love how can it be that thou my
God
should die for me that freaks many
people out of course there's a lot of
people that can't sing that so I want to
sing it and when I sing it I want to
shout it yes like we've heard before yes
I don't want to mumble it
I want to shout it because that's what I
believe
and I want everybody on the planet
whether he is Muslim or whether he is
Hindu or whether he is Catholic I want
him to know that I believe that
therefore I have to shout it that he can
hear it amen amen
and then they refrain amazing love how
can it be that thou my God should die
for me
pertinent
how much theology is in that that is
complete biblical Doctrine yes in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was God
he left his father's throne above so
free so infinite his grace emptied
himself of all but love and bled for
Adam's helpless race
this Mercy all immense and free for oh
my God it found out me
so why was he found
because of Grace and infinite grace of
the father is it a conversion song yes
he found him right yes converted
repented what converted him his
understanding of what's going on over
there does he have a Biblical
understanding
of the Plan of Salvation oh for sure you
can't sing that if you don't have that
now right true
and if you can't sing that then you're
not a Christian then you know you're a
pagan exactly you're not walking the
true path
long my imprisoned Spirit lay fast Bound
in sin and Nature's night
thine eye defused a quickening ray I
woke the dungeon flamed with light My
Chains fell off my heart was free I Rose
went forth and followed thee
is there theology in that
is repentance is it a call yes did it
happen to the disciples yes
so why did they follow him
and why did they come out of their
dungeons we're all in dungeons we are in
prisons yes so there's a lot of theology
in that I can sing that happened to me
if it didn't happen to me I couldn't
call myself a Christian that's it did it
happen to you yeah so can you identify
with it absolutely the danger and in a
dungeon is it important to be able to
identify with what you think
100 percent
all right
no condemnation now I dread Jesus and
all in him is mine alive in him my
living head
and clothed in righteousness divine bold
I approach the Eternal throne and
claimed the crown through Christ my own
is there confidence in that yes
is there theology in that the promise
that God and Jesus gave to us
is there embraced is righteousness by
faith in there that's it
Martin
nobody but a true Christian can sing
that song
and if they do and they're not true
Christians they're Hypocrites yeah they
have to believe what this says
now the original lyrics actually contain
another verse this is the same one the
first one
but read this one for us Martin
this mystery or the immortal Dies who
can explore his strange design in vain
the firstborn serif tries to sound the
depths of love divine this Mercy all let
Earth adore let Angel Minds inquire no
more
now they leave that one out in the
modern hymnals because it's a little bit
complex
I love it
theology in this I would shout it even
louder
I like the theology so therefore I want
to shout it in other words sing it with
gusto
's Mercy all the immortal dies that's an
oxymoron exactly we've seen that happen
every time even the Bible uses it so the
Bible is full of oxymorons
so who can explore his strange design
are we ever going to understand that not
even the first born Seraph yeah I can
understand that
but he has to look at it and make it he
studied this Mercy awe let Earth adore
let Angels Minds inquire no more it
should set us it should Boggle the minds
of whether you are an angel or whether
you are a human being
but you don't have to because just
believe it
so in the original there were five
verses yeah but they took out that
complex once and now they have four so
in our hymnals that would be number four
yeah no common condemnation now I dread
so it's a beautiful theological hymn and
the refrain is my God should die for me
and that is something you really want to
shout yeah
and would you imagine Martin that that
would irritate the devil
like Martin Luther said he runs he flies
away it must irritate him endlessly so I
want to shout it even more yeah
that's I agree with you 100 percent
all right so what is the history of the
same we don't have to read it again for
him
and can it be that I should gain as
perhaps one of the most joyfully
Perignon hymns penned by Charles Wesley
on whitsunday that's Pentecost three
days before his brother John experienced
his heart strangely warmed
Charles was convalescing in the home of
John Bray a poor mechanic
when he heard a voice saying in the name
of Jesus of Nazareth arise and believe
and thou shalt be healed of all thy
infirmities
the voice was most likely Mr Bray's
sister who felt commanded to say these
words in a dream
interesting histories right
so these hymns didn't just appear one
day
so what I'm going to write about today
no no no no there's a there is an
experience and and an emotional issue
involved
and normally once they've probably
studied something or yes yeah
I mean how do you
work out a sermon
if it becomes a drag
and you have to think oh brother what am
I going to preach on today
then perhaps you should go on holiday
it's true if that's where you're at and
you are a preacher or somebody that's
evangelist if it starts getting oh
get go on a break correct if you keep
reading your Bible
if you keep reading Spirit of Prophecy
you will have no end of sermons to
preach
so Anglican hymn writer Timothy Dudley
Smith notes that the following then
happened
Charles got out of bed and opened his
Bible and read from the Psalms
he have put a new song in my mouth even
praise unto our God followed by the
first verse of Isaiah 40. Comfort ye
Comfort ye my people says your God he
wrote in his journal I have found myself
at peace with God
and rejoiced in the hope of the love of
Christ
the statement from Mr Bray's sister
sparked within Charles conviction like
he had never felt before
moved and convicted in spirit child
wrestled with these words until he came
to rest in his faith
knowing that is by faith that we are
saved
it comes back to that theme right it was
it was born out of justification by
faith again correct
and soon after this conversion
experience he wrote two hymns in
celebration of the amazing love he had
come to know and can it be that I should
gain and where shall my wandering Soul
begin comes in the United Methodist
Hymnal the um
there has been some debate as to which
him was written first but most current
scholarship accepts the latter as the
first hymn written by Charles after his
conversion experience no matter
its place in the chronology of Wesley's
output and can it be has been and
remains one of his most remarkable hymns
expressing like no other the rapturous
joy of receiving salvation
you know people can search on the web
and have different
choirs or individuals
sing it
and then they could listen to the Pathos
and the the energy that goes into it and
internalize the words
and see whether it lifts you to a higher
plane or
becomes a mantra yeah
so the text of the hymn is fairly
straightforward Wesley opens with an
exclamation and can it be that I should
gain an interest in the savior's blood
these words are followed by a rhetorical
question daddy for me who caused his
pain
both are typical of child's poetic style
the imagery he uses for each standard is
Perignon and particularly in the case of
stanza IV is reminiscent of both Peter
and Paul's miraculous release from
prison the dungeon that he talks about
As Told in Acts 12 16 respectively the
first stanza expresses wonder and
amazement at the Redemptive Act of God
and his offering of free Grace to all
even those who cause his pain
this wonder is further emphasized by the
repeated phrase for me
in lines three and four
the second standard continues the sense
of awe with the opening line This
mystery all the immortal dies
yet Charles captures the Paradox of the
passal mystery the Redemptive death and
resurrection of Christ
saying that even the chief of the Angels
cannot fathom the depth of this love
divine
and in stanza 3 he speaks about the
Incarnation echoing Philippians 2 6-8
in lines three and four emptied himself
of all but love and bled for Adam's
helpless race
stanza 4 Compares Humanity's Newfound
freedom from sin to that of Peter's
miraculous release from prison
so Wesley borrows a line from a popular
story of romantic fiction from his day
eloisa the Apple art by Alexander Pope
thine eye defused the quickening ray to
symbolize God's love and power coming
down to release the captives
so in stanza 5 Wesley speaks of the
present justification we now have in
Christ and our future glorification in
the Life to Come
the first line no condemnation now I
dread alludes to Romans 8 1 therefore
there is now no common condemnation for
those who are in Christ Jesus
so is there deep theology in it
but this was his conversion
Martin what knowledge did these people
have before it actually hit them it's
amazing huh yes that I mean all this
theology was already there and then only
said well I convert repent what song
enters your heart and your mind
when you become converted
well it contains
remorse
gladness
and joy there are some hymns which stand
out which which you related to when you
were working yes I understand yeah and
it'll be different for everyone right
for me for instance that's why I sang oh
glorious love yes in my darkness Jesus
found me correct
a lot and I was an atheist right and
when I discovered what Christ had done
for me
A Hymn that resonated with me was so
sweet to trust in Jesus just to take him
at his word
which I'd never done before right yeah
and it it had a very powerful impact on
me and that's why we used it also in the
total Onslaught Series yeah and people
say you know the total Onslaught series
is not
always christ-centered enough because it
has a lot of focus on everything that's
wrong in the world the great controversy
and all those issues
why would I choose that theme song If
it's not Christ sent him because once
you've got rid of the garbage and all
that's left is Christ that's it and if
you that's to show all the deceptions
taking you away from Christ so it is
Christ centered because all of that is
to take your set take away the smoke
screen get you back to you get you back
to Christ that's so sweet to trust in
Jesus so the modern there are certain
hymns that resonate with the person
but they have to have a
theological depth to them
so the hymn was first appeared in John
Wesley's 1739 hymnal
hymns and sacred poems since its first
publication it has been included in most
Methodist hymnals and in the hymnals of
many other Protestant denominations you
know it's almost like the methodists
took
the hymn issue to a higher level I mean
he wrote six thousand songs
and adventism is very much rooted in
methodism
because methodism For the First Time
also emphasized sanctification
can't just remain with justification
because without sanctification no one
will see God in other words with owing
without allowing Christ to transform you
yes and stay there you cannot have
eternal life
you must be transformed
so
aside from their mission by John of the
original fifth stanza in his 1780 Hymnal
the hymn has remained in its original
form
this missing span stanza speaks of
personal Assurance of Salvation perhaps
Wesley admitted it because of its overly
personal tone
and its relatively small contribution to
the overall theme and structure of the
hymn
its personal character may be most
appropriate in some more Evangelical
settings but it is of little consequence
to the general worshiping community
now
whether it is in or not if it doesn't
change it that's fair enough I would
prefer them to be in
as a Martin would you agree with me that
to a very large extent
we have lost
the importance of hymns
you know where I see that as when you go
into a church and they sing hymns and
like you said it's
[Music]
everybody is actually irritated yeah of
the if you go into a church and it's the
same hymns but it's sung with gusto and
a shout
it's totally different totally different
it all depends on the state of the mind
and the state of the heart
and hymns are not boring
the only thing boring about it is the
people that make it boring you are
absolutely right so let's close with uh
a quote from the spirit of Prophecy
the art of sacred melody was diligently
cultivated in the school of the prophets
no frivolous Waltz was heard no flippant
song that should extol man and divert
attention from God
but sacred solemn psalms of praise to
the Creator exalting his name and
recounting his wondrous Works thus music
was made to serve a holy purpose to lift
the thoughts to that which was pure and
Noble and elevating and to awaken in the
soul devotion and gratitude to God that
is
the issue
we should get back to this form of
worship
and we should study why we are singing
what we are singing what does it mean
what we are singing and how does it
apply to me personally then we won't sit
there with a mumbling yeah and
what happens when you get into a church
and the before the sermons and
everything starts you've got opening
worship song worship and everybody is
singing that whole Divine service
just flows in with that correct
music forms part of God's Worship in the
courts above
and we should Endeavor in our songs of
praise to approach as nearly as possible
to the harmony of the Heavenly choirs
the proper training of the voice is an
important feature in education and
should not be neglected
singing is a part of religious service
is as much an act of worship as his
prayer the heart must feel the spirit of
the song to give it right expression
but that's the basis
of the meaning of songs of praise to God
and if we can ReDiscover this
what a what a difference it will make
well in the past seven years
this whole thing about music has really
transformed in my life
and I must tell you that
once you allow God to change
what you perceive to be correct and what
he actually wants to be correct in
Sacred Music
the whole world opens up in in that
milia correct so may God give us wisdom
as we contemplate these things these
were just a few ideas as to what
constitutes true worship of a high and
holy God may God give us wisdom right I
mean let's pray
Heavenly Father
we want to serve you not only in
Doctrine
but in song as well
and we want to be part of that Heavenly
experience those heavenly choirs
we want to sing with joy with gratitude
and with an understanding of the Plan of
Salvation
so that people can know what we stand
for what we believe why we believe it
and why we want to shout it to the world
give us a new experience
May the true holy spirit
reawaken that which has been lost is my
prayer in Jesus name amen amen
thank you